who went on to work with animals after a
career on the disney channel does the
kid from erie indiana have an
appropriately weird job now that he's an
adult not all former child stars burn
out some of them just quietly move on to
other professions in stanley kubrick's
classic 1980 adaptation of stephen
king's the shining the role of the
troubled psychically gifted danny
torrance was played by newcomer danny
lloyd
lloyd discussed his time making the
horror film in a 2017 interview with the
guardian as he revealed that he enjoyed
the experience and has fond memories of
it but he hasn't kept up an acting
career in the decades since his reasons
for leaving the industry have nothing to
do with the film itself instead the work
just dried up for him lloyd continued to
audition a process that can be grueling
but he didn't mind it too much as he
told the guardian i always enjoyed it it
was exciting but as i got a little bit
older it got kind of boring then i had
to tell my parents that i was ready to
quit which they were fine with they were
never stage parents they made sure i had
a normal upbringing these days lloyd is
a biology professor at a community
college in kentucky and he's happy with
the showbiz legacy according to him i
don't regret trying acting when i
decided to stop i don't regret that
either
if you know mara wilson you most likely
recognize her from early 90s family
classics like mrs doubtfire miracle on
34th street and of course as the title
character in matilda she was one of
those child stars who seemed to be wise
beyond her years at no point did it ever
appear like she was mugging for the
camera or attempting too hard to be a
cute kid instead there was a natural
quality in her performances that was
absolutely unique to her and that may
very well be why her work in those films
is still fondly remembered all these
years later while talking to npr in 2016
wilson explained that her departure from
acting happened gradually almost without
her even realizing it after her mother's
passing acting became the only constant
in her life but she didn't have the same
enthusiasm for it as puberty struck she
was embarrassed by the natural processes
of growing up and it was difficult to go
through publicly eventually she found
that she could survive without acting so
she instead focused on writing she
composed a play called sheeple in 2013
and her memoir where am i now was
released in 2016. where is she now where
did she disappear to
k panabeker began her career in 2001 in
a short film called temptation and she
also recorded some voices in the
animated pixar classic monsters inc her
star then rose so quickly that she
worked almost non-stop for the next 10
years she showed up on tv shows like
angel and law order special victims unit
while also co-starring in the disney
channel series phil of the future
additionally she appeared in tv movies
like read it and weep alongside her
older sister danielle and one of the
biggest titles on her resume is the 2009
remake of fame despite her continued
success panabaker ultimately decided to
walk away from acting she revealed to
her fans on twitter her very simple
reason for leaving the entertainment
industry behind while also sharing some
life advice as she wrote i just lost the
love for acting life is short we spend
too much time at work gotta do what you
love and i love my job that job that she
loves so much is working with animals as
she now has a gig as a zookeeper at
disney world's animal kingdom
it would be hard to imagine anyone
living on planet earth for the past few
decades who hasn't heard of the olsen
twins the pair absolutely dominated
family entertainment during the early
1990s they got their start playing
youngest sister michelle tanner on the
iconic family sitcom full house and they
then shot into the pop culture
stratosphere thanks to their numerous tv
movies like to grandmother's house we go
and double double toil and trouble as
well as a mountain of direct video
movies and other official merchandise in
2006 the olsen twins launched the row a
luxury fashion line that they've worked
on perfecting for over 15 years in a
rare interview they sat down with id
magazine in 2021 to celebrate the
success of their venture the
conversation included very little
discussion of their acting careers
though they did mention that the reason
they're not open with the public about
their lives is they've always been
discreet people as that's how they were
raised while we may not know their exact
reasons for entering the fashion world
and leaving entertainment behind it
seems pretty clear that they're happy
with their current careers
lyanna creel's biggest claim to fame is
probably the 10 episodes of saved by the
bell she appeared in during the show's
final season in which she was set up as
a foil for zack morris she played the
headstrong torrey scott who wouldn't
fall easily for his charm before that
her first credit was in another beloved
series a 1987 episode of the abc sitcom
growing pains shortly afterwards she and
her sisters starred in the tv movies
parent trap 3 and parent trap hawaiian
honeymoon alongside acting legend haley
mills who starred in the original parent
trap movie as well as good morning miss
bliss a series that became saved by the
bell creole may not be acting anymore
but she's still involved with producing
visual content through creel studio a
production company that she runs with
her wife it's the company's commitment
to philanthropy that really helps it
stand out according to its website we
believe the good life is about more than
just material comforts it's also about
living a life marked by doing good in
illuminating all aspects of the good
life we convey an enlightened sense of
luxury lifestyle content creole also
started an app that assists real estate
professionals in creating content
originally a dancer amy foster is
probably best remembered for two
projects the 1989 shelley long comedy
troop beverly hills which was about a
troop of rich privileged girl scouts and
the nbc sitcom punky brewster on which
she played the rich entitled and
slightly oblivious margot but those are
only two credits on a long and
impressive resume that foster assembled
over the course of an 11 year acting
career while catching up with her punky
co-star cherry johnson on the cherries
world podcast in 2021 foster discussed
what she's been up to since walking away
from acting for a brief time she entered
the music industry and moved to
nashville however she wanted to be with
her family in los angeles and her
husband got a job there working as a
firefighter after the birth of her
daughter she decided that she would
rather be home instead of working in
showbiz so she might have the most
grown-up gig of anybody on this list
michael oliver's career may have only
lasted six years but when your first
role out of the gate is the meanest
little kid in cinema there isn't much
else you need to do after that he also
had small roles in other notable movies
like forrest gump and a racer but it's
his portrayal of junior and problem
child and problem child 2 that left the
biggest impact in 2015 oliver was a
guest on his problem child co-star
gilbert gottfried's amazing colossal
podcast the two reminisced about working
on the original film learning from the
late john ritter and what happened to
oliver in the years since around the
time that oliver's parents pursued legal
action against the studio for failing to
pay them the money they were owed they
lost their house and he was losing
interest in acting he likened his life
experience to the opposite of a kid
wondering what it must be like to be
famous to him he was looking at the
lives of normal kids and wondering what
that was like at the time of the
interview he was working in the tech
support industry
the biggest title on omri katz's resume
is probably the prime time soap opera
dallas on which he played john ross
ewing iii but anyone who grew up in the
early 90s will surely know him best for
the quirky tv show eerie indiana and the
halloween classic hocus pocus he also
worked with director joe dante in the
1993 movie matinee a cult classic ode to
60s b-movie schlock and cold war
tensions in march 2020 katz posted a
message on his instagram that he was
getting into the cannabis apparel
business as he wrote being a member of
the cannabis community for almost 20
years now and jumping through hoops of
fire to get here i'm proud to announce
our online apparel store will be opening
up soon the store in question is called
the married dangsters and the about
section on the website declares we the
merry dangsters are ambassadors of the
cannabis culture with deep roots within
the traditional cannabis community we
represent positivity herb and unity
ariana richards appeared in a few films
and tv shows in the 90s that are still a
big deal today she surely best
remembered his lex in the original
jurassic park additionally she also
appeared alongside kevin bacon in 1990s
tremors she played the title character's
love interest in 1995's angus and she
turned in a heartbreaking performance as
a young girl being abused by her father
in an episode of boy meets world in 2020
richards spoke with amblin entertainment
about her experience making jurassic
park and what her life's like now a
painter from an early age she took part
in a mentorship through the california
arts club after college she credits
everything she learned during those four
years with sending her down her current
path as a professional painter
eva amore started her acting career in
the 1992 film bob roberts alongside the
father of her half siblings tim robbins
her mother is actress susan sarandon and
the two work together in dead man
walking earthly possessions anywhere but
here and the banger sisters amore also
appeared on huge tv shows like friends
and how i met your mother her acting
career was still going strong for
several years until she ultimately
decided to step away in 2016. following
the birth of her daughter amore realized
that she couldn't raise a child to spend
her life doing something that made her
happy when she wasn't doing that herself
while talking with yahoo finance in 2019
she explained that she made a list of
things that did make her happy her
then-husband told her it looked like a
lifestyle blog and he encouraged her to
learn how to make a living in an online
space her blog happily eva after then
launched in 2015 and it covers her
favorite topics which are style decor
food and crafting
even if you've never seen a single film
starring this tiny mega star chances are
you still recognize the name simply put
there would be no olsen twins empire
without shirley temple her image was so
recognizable and popular that it was
plastered all over various kinds of
merchandise in the 1930s she was such a
huge star so early in life but then she
retired from acting at the tender age of
22 considering that she started her life
on screen at the age of three and
starred in 34 films over a 14-year
period it's safe to say that she had a
full career before most people even got
started
during the late 50s and into the early
60s temple briefly returned to
entertainment both in front of and
behind the camera she then transitioned
to a new role in 1969 when she became a
diplomat as she traveled around the
world she witnessed atrocities that put
her on track to becoming the ambassador
to ghana in 1974
and then in 1989 she was appointed by
president george h.w bush to be the
first female ambassador to
czechoslovakia check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite actors
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you